[Musique]
et bonsoir Lilian comme chaque soir
focus sur un canton et ce soir on part
dans liyonne oui nous choisissons chaque
soir une problématique particulière
celle qui caractérise le canton d'osser
1 nous l'avions peu abordé jusque-là
c'est la suite des élections municipales
le match retour en quelque sorte ce
canton d'osérin est constitué de trois
communes et d'une partie de la ville on
se souvient de l'élection municipale
très serré l'an passé au cours de
laquelle le socialiste gu ferrez avait
résisté de peu à la vague bleue menée
par le député Guillaume l'arrivé et bien
sur ce canton on trouve le premier
adjoint gufferz et une colistière de
Guillaume l'arrivé reportage de basiste
jaouti et Claude Heude Guy Paris
conseiller général il a beau être
conseiller général sortant Guy Paris est
en campagne comme n'importe quel autre
candidat il se présente pour la gauche
est aussi premier adjoint au maire
d'osser mais ne part pas sous
l'étiquette socialiste accompagné de sa
binome Christine Léman coursy
conseillère municipal à saint-georgees
et de leur remplaçant il va au devant
des électeurs il nous dit
un certain nombre de choses qui sont pas
toujours bonnes à entendre mais en tout
cas il faut les prendre en considération
et ce que moi je dis c'est qu'on est sur
une campagne départementale pour des
sujets qui sont tout autres que les
décisions qui peuvent être pris prises
au niveau
nationalelle Gén à 42 ans Valérie leg
elle se présentera pour la première fois
sur son nom propre devant les électeurs
sur ce canton d'ser 1 elle part avec
l'expérimenté Michel Ducou 67 ans prère
joint au maire de
Saint-Georges assistante parlementaire
du jeune sénateur Jean-Baptiste Lemoine
Valérie legug a fait plusieurs campagnes
au côté de Guillaume larrivée mais elle
se veut d'abord au service des électeurs
de la droite et sa famille politique on
est sur un sujet
départemental ni Guy Paris ni moi-même
ne sommes des pions je veux dire nous
sommes soutenus je suppose que gu Paris
est largement soutenu par gu ferz et
moimême je suis largement soutenue par
toute la droite départementale c'est pas
une
revanche c'est c'est c'est une nouvelle
échéance la zuup d'ser et le quartier
saintjn viève l'un des secteurs clés du
nouveau canton Alain Raymon y est un peu
en terrain connu candidat avec Pascal
Marlin pour l'extrême gauche il présente
leur programme aux habitants les incite
à aller voter eux prendnent une
véritable politique de gauche et
fustigent d'abord le gouvernement au
pouvoir il a la droite l'extrême droite
ça c'est c'est clair il y a le Parti
socialiste mais qu'on voit pas bien sous
l'étiquette
qui Ren àne mais bon c gensl notamment
le Parti socialiste aujourd'hui ce sont
des libéraux qui acceptent l'austérité
qui acceptent les dogmes européens sur
les budgets avec des communes pér
urbaines comme l'indri ou ville Fargeot
mais aussi des quartiers populaires à
oser comme la ZUP donc la ZAC
Saint-Siméon ou encore les Brichères le
nouveau canton
er 1 dessine pour le Front national des
ambitions élevées avec Kevin moué
commercial au serroi de 22 ans et
Angélique Cholet 27 ans et serveuse dans
un restaurant le partte fait le choix de
la jeunesse de la proximité avec les
électeurs là aujourd'hui que ce soit le
pouvoir d'achat que ce soit le budget on
arrive au 10 du mois les gens ont leur
enfin le 5 on va dire les gens leur
payent le 10 ils ont plus rien et nous
actuellement avec Angélique et moi euh
on est du peuple on est pareil on sait
comment la vie est dure actuellement on
sait que à la fin du mois c'est dur pour
tout le monde et justement on veut aider
à ce que ça soit mieux fort des derniers
sondages le Front national espère
enlever trois cantons dans Lyonne à ses
élections départementales sur
oser 1 il se voit bien jouer les
troubles faites profiter de la faible
participation annoncée pour briser le
traditionnel duel gauche-doite de TR qu
fois par semaine et la campagne se'est
déroulé à nouveau beaucoup sur internet
aujourd'hui oui et alors pour tout dire
elle est même devenue folle à un moment
donné avec une bonne dose de surréalisme
surtout chez les candidats de Lyonne on
a commencé avec un proverbe sibilin de
Thierry corneot candidat à
Saint-Florentin pendant que certains
vend du vent d'autres construisent des
éoliennes comprennent qui pourra on
suppose que les intéressés se sont
reconnus ça s'est gâté avec
Jean-Baptiste Le Moine sédateur et
candidat UMP à la tribune du Sénat pour
débattre du service civil jusque-l tout
va bien sauf que comme un juré de la
Nouvelle Star il s'est amusé à placer
des nom dans son discours citer triane
et Grand Corps Malade à la tribune du
Sénat c'est fait comme quoi on rigole
aussi au Sénat ça veut dire qu'on peut
proposer des noms je sais pas Rolling
Stone nou Florent P pour fois on va
essayer on va le faire en attendant ça
s'est encore gâté à la mi-journée on est
parti dans le grand n'importe quoi
encore dans Lyonne entre notre pistolero
du tweet Pascal Simon Assens et le
député européen Front national Édouard
Ferrand enfin bref tout part de ce tweet
de Pascal Simon vous le voyez qui tire à
la sulfateuse sur le front national en
parlant de simple d'esprit quelques
minutes plus tard réponse d'Édouard
Ferrand qui se moque de son adversaire
en évoquant une déculotée à venir
l'adversaire en question lui renvoie
ilico qu'il est aller se faire élire aux
européennes dans le Sud-Ouest alors
qu'il avait mené campagne municipale à
Sens et c'est vrai à ce moment-là du du
coup l'élu Front national prend la
hauteur en parlant de grâce et de
Saint-Simon et le socialiste lui choisit
la référence à Saint-Juste
révolutionnaire inflexible avec des
rillettes et du cornichon et là ça
devient vraiment n'importe quoi et je ne
résiste pas à vous rajouter cette
formule surréaliste du sénateur UMP de
cô d'or Alain ouperre qui nous avait
déjà régalé pendant les municipales la
peur de tomber fait grimacer l'pendu
c'est bien pour finir allez une dernière
info qui VI nous parvenir elle concerne
la son oui c'est beaucoup plus sérieux
d'après nos informations les candidats
UMP qui se présentent en sonéloire à la
chapelle de gincheille sur Macon 1
contre les candidats officiels du parti
viennent d'être suspendus par le Bureau
national de l'UMP Gérard voisin l'ancien
député Marie-Pierre sirudin Valérie
Nadal et Jean-Philippe Belleville serait
donc suspendu par un courrier de Laurent
Vauquier qu' leur reproche de semmer la
confusion et la désunion il semble bien
qu'on parle de suspension et pas
d'exclusion il y a une ambiance très
compliquée en sonéloire dans la région
maconnaise à l'UMP merci Lilian à demain
on parlera de Dijon 3